So basically I'm just like going through it, and then like talking about it.
Once I did the bow, I felt like that's when my mind cleared, and then, that's good.
Pretty good, I think.
After all my kicks, I felt a little bit off balance, but when I was doing those motions,
I felt pretty in control.
And then going forward.
I think this was like, I felt smooth, like in control, like in the zone.
Yeah, most of my hand motions felt like pretty like in control.
I think whenever I was getting to the kicks, I kind of felt like a little bit off balance
when I was getting there, but stance seemed pretty good.
I could have probably extended a little bit more on my side kicks, but going through it,
here was kind of like, again, just gathering everything.
I think I might have gone a second too long on that motion, but, and going back, felt
pretty good.
And then, yeah, just whenever I was going through the hands, I felt good.
The kicks kind of like threw me off a little, but, yeah, I felt pretty in the zone.
Pretty good.
Yeah.